[Music]
courtney is in canton ohio hi courtney
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
i wanted to hear that um so uh
not quite sure
the shortened version of this
basically uh
i don't have much of an income right now
uh i'm basing my only income right now
is door dashing i am about to take an
exam to get my insurance license
to get an actual income and have an
actual job um
with the limited income that i have i've
been trying to do your baby steps for i
can't tell you how long
unfortunately it
because of another relationship that i
ended back in february was why i
couldn't really fully dave
do the baby steps
at this point i have five dollars in
savings
my question is what is the best way
to
still
work towards that end goal of at least
creating that thousand dollar
starter emergency fund with only having
about a hundred dollars a week
how come you're only making 100 bucks a
week how many hours are you doing
doordash
as often as i can uh
a week what else do you do what's taking
up your time
i don't have a babysitter
so it's child care i have tried yes i
have tried numerous people and they've
all
it was either my teenage sister being a
teenage girl or the other person that i
was able to find it got better can you
find work from home right now maybe a
customer service job online
uh studying to take my exam took up a
lot of the past couple weeks not on
insurance
yes an insurance exam is not that hard
no i um
how old are you very i don't know
25. okay all right
um here's the thing before this i had i
was trying to start like an in-home
cleaning business so i had income since
february but since then it's it didn't
i guess i guess proved to
be as successful as i wanted it to be
just what you don't need is an income
you need to allocate more hours to work
some way or another
you've got to find some way to go make
some money
because you don't have any money
you don't even know money pay for food
right
100 a week when you pay for it i get
assistance in that but yeah no if i
didn't have that assistance i know i
wouldn't i wouldn't be able to care what
kind of assistance
uh
oh okay all right
well here here's the thing the reason
you don't have any money is you don't
work much
so we've got to find some way
we you
have to find some way to find some hours
or some method
uh that the kid rides along with you i
don't know what it is that you go make
money
because that's your problem
there's not going to be a situation what
happened if you got like a full-time job
making 100 000 a year well you'd have to
find a babysitter
yeah you know and what happens when you
get ready to go sell some insurance
you're gonna have to find a babysitter
so you're a single mom and you're gonna
solve that equation and that's that's
the problem you've got there's no magic
wand that makes a hundred dollars a week
work
we don't have one of those
so what this is a an income crisis kiddo
you have an income crisis
and you need to treat it that way
this is the ramsay show